der Herbst ist für uns die Zeit des
haltbarmachens und des vorsorgens für
den Winter die ganzen Früchte werden
reif die Nüsse liegen unter den Bäumen
wir verarbeiten jetzt auch ganz viel
Fleisch und föhnen unsere Vorratskammer
bis sich die Regalbretter unter den
ganzen Gläsern und Kürbissen biegen mein
Ziel ist es möglichst viel von dem was
wir essen selber zu erzeugen aber nicht
um jeden Preis ich mache einfach das was
mir Spaß macht in den Rest lasse ich
sein ich habe einen sehr großen
Gemüsegarten wie Enden unser eigenes
Obst wir haben auch Hühner zur
eierhaltung oft auch Ziegen für Milch
und Fleisch mein Freund ist Jäger so
dass wir da auch Fleisch herbekommen
aber im Prinzip sind die Milchprodukte
und das Fleisch das einzige was richtig
satt macht vielleicht noch die Eier
vielleicht noch die Kartoffeln aus dem
Garten und noch so zwei drei andere
Pflanzen die wir im Garten anbauen
Sachen die wir selber anbauen und die
auch richtig satt machen werden zum
Beispiel Kürbisse Topinambur oder zum
Beispiel den meisten nicht anbaue also
das ist kein zuckermeister sein Mais für
Polenta und zum Backen und da kommt
natürlich auch an Kalorien und an
Kohlenhydraten ordentlich was rum aber
trotzdem sind wir Meilen weit davon
entfernt hier irgendwie zu 100% autark
zu sein wir waren die letzten Tage mal
wieder fleißig hier haben wir
zimtpflaumen eingekocht diesmal in
kleineren Portionsgrößen weil mir die
oft schlecht geworden sind dann
natürlich Tomatensoße hier haben wir sie
ziemlich eklig aus aber es ist wirklich
lecker das ist nur so eklig weil sich
das Fett oben so absetzt das ist
Knochenbrühe aus zwei Rehen die wir
verarbeitet haben und hier ist
Knochenbrühe sehr großen Hirsch den mein
Freund geschossen hat sind auch noch ein
paar Liter geworden ein kleiner
Vergleich das ist das schmalste sich von
dem einen Hirsch gewonnen habe und das
ist das schmeißt dass ich von zwei Rehen
gewonnen habe also der war schon
deutlich fetter ich habe auch schon
Schmalz vor meinen Ziegen hergestellt
das hat aber einen ziemlich strengen
Eigengeschmack und das hirschmalz
schmeckt im Vergleich zu Bratkartoffeln
etc einfach viel viel milder und viel
lecker wichtig ist natürlich wenn die
Gläser jetzt abgekühlt sind die Klammern
abzumachen das Vakuum hält dann den
Deckel sowieso fest auf dem Glas drauf
weil wenn das verdirbt dann löst sich in
den allermeisten Fällen das Vakuum und
das würde man so einfach viel schneller
merken als wenn man die Klammern dran
ist
[Musik]
die Klammern von diesen kleinen Schmuck
Gläsern abzukriegen ist wirklich die
Hölle ich kann euch gleich noch mal mehr
zu den unterschiedlichen Glastypen
erzählen die ich verwende das hier ist
auf jeden Fall eine sehr hübsche Form
aber aus verschiedenen Gründen total
unpraktisch und dann haben wir dieses
Jahr auch zum ersten Mal richtig viele
Pilze gesammelt und verarbeitet
gerade die Parasole klein wir haben
jetzt so viel von denen gehabt dass ich
die jetzt auf jeden Fall darin werde für
den Winter
[Musik]
und dann habe ich noch jede Menge
tortenfleisch das jetzt auch noch mit in
den Dörrautomaten wandert
[Musik]
letzte Woche habe ich schon ungefähr
drei Kilo Trockenfleisch aus Bree
gemacht drei Kilo
habt ihr schon alles aufgefutter
[Musik]
es gibt direkt Laser ja in den aller
buntesten verschiedenen Formen und
verschiedene Formen haben auch
unterschiedliche Vor- und Nachteile und
ich benutze vor allem diese drei Formen
natürlich müsst ihr euch keine
Einkochgläser kaufen man kann auch
Supermarkt Altglas verwenden vor allem
wenn man im Wasserbad einkocht und nicht
im Druck Einkochtopf Druck ein Kochtopf
doch eher die dickwandigen verwenden
weil die sonst springen könnten aber das
Supermarkt als das könnt ihr einfach
weiter verwenden es kostet euch nichts
nur darauf achten dass die Deckel
weiterhin intakt sind weil wenn die
verbeult sind kann es das schlecht
werden oder das bildet sich erst gar
kein Vakuum die Schmuckform mag ich vor
allem nur deswegen weil sie sehr schön
aussieht und das ist auch wichtig im
Vorratsregal aber man sieht das ja hier
die hat so einen dicken Bauch und eine
kleinere Öffnung und deswegen ist es zum
Beispiel für Marmelade total unpraktisch
weil man die gar nicht so richtig aus
dem Glas rausbekommt mit dem Messer man
kriegt das Glas nicht so leicht sauber
und die Klammern lassen sich vor allem
bei den ganz kleinen Schmuck Gläsern die
in verschiedenen Größen lassen sich die
Klammern einfach super schwer ablösen so
Mittelding ist das tulpenglas das hat
auch noch so eine schöne Rundung hat
aber zum Beispiel die Vorteile dass man
es viel besser sauber bekommt und das
auch wenn man die im Regal lagert nicht
so viel Luft dazwischen ist das heißt
der Platz im Regal wird hier schon viel
besser ausgenutzt am allerliebsten mag
ich aber diese ganz einfachen
Sturzgläser kriegt man schnell sauber
die kann man easy stapeln das ist auch
wirklich sehr sehr sehr praktisch wenn
man viele einkaufsgläser hat und schaut
mal was hier gerade aus dem der
Automaten kommt
es ist gerade eine Runde Trockenfleisch
fertig geworden das lagere ich immer
noch Stoffseite das ist echt schön dass
irgendwie mal mit dem Garten zu nehmen
oder auf eine Wanderung mitzunehmen und
dann einfach in den kleinen Snack dabei
zu haben und sogar manchmal einfach mit
ins Büro ich habe übrigens einen
Onlinekurs zum haltbar machen von Obst
und Gemüse also diejenigen von euch die
da Lust drauf haben das richtig zu
lernen und alles wissen dass ich mir in
den letzten jahrzehn Jahren angeeignet
habe
aufbereitet zusammengefasst mit tollen
Rezepten bestückte auf dem
Serviertablett zu bekommen der Link ist
unten in der Videobeschreibung oder ich
finde den auch unter
wurzelwerk.net/kurse und falls das vom
Budget her gerade einfach nicht drin ist
habe ich auch noch einen dreiteiligen
Kurs der kostet 0 €. da könnt ihr euch
auch für anmelden der Link ist auch
unten in der Videobeschreibung den habe
ich einfach für meinen Newsletter
erstellt und damit einfach mal
reinschnuppern könnt und gucken könnt ob
euch meine Kurse denn gefallen würden da
lernt man auch schon richtig viel der
heißt mach deine Ernte haltbar Challenge
und dann wollen wir ja noch unsere Pilze
eintüten bzw Einblasen ein Gläsern
ich achte immer darauf dass ich nach dem
Trockenvorgang nicht zu lange warte also
dass die nicht wieder Wasser aus der
Luft ziehen können weil die dann auch im
Glas verderben können sondern die sind
jetzt quasi noch ein bisschen warm und
gerade fertig gedörrt und jetzt kommen
die direkt in das Glas und dann einfach
wieder aufweichen wenn man dann welche
verwenden möchte und bei uns vergeht
definitiv kein Herbst ohne dass wir
fruchtleder herstellen fruchtleder ist
für uns ein bisschen der
gummibärchenersatz beziehungsweise sowas
wie eine selbstgemachte Süßigkeit
schmeckt super lecker dadurch dass es
gedörrt ist schmeckt es auch richtig
richtig süß sowie zum Beispiel Aprikosen
auch viel süßer werden wenn man sieht
hört als sie vorher sind mit dem ganzen
Wasser noch drin und jetzt schneide ich
einfach Streifen ab lass das Backpapier
dran dann kriegt man nicht so klebrige
Finger wenn man die sich wieder auf die
Glas rausfischt und dann lagere ich die
einfach in diesem Glas die halten sich
auf mehrere Jahre ohne Probleme wenn man
es nicht vorher aufnimmt
[Musik]
in der den Fehler
ein paar von euch werden es
wahrscheinlich wissen Gläser sollte man
bei der Lagerung nie stapeln liegt daran
dass das obere Glas hier auf das untere
Glas drauf drückt und damit den Deckel
nach unten presst und so können
eventuell entstehende Fäulnisgase nicht
so leicht entweichen und wir als
Vorratskammer Besitzer können nicht so
leicht checken ob vielleicht etwas bei
unseren Vorräten verdorben ist
übrigens die komplette Leber von einem
höher schaltet ihr gedacht dass die so
groß ist wenn man Leberwurst macht dann
braucht man ich glaube nur so 20 % Leber
und der Rest ist einfach normales
Fleisch das heißt wir werden jetzt gut
versorgt seine Leberwurst aber das ist
auch wieder sowas wir haben das nicht
geschafft diesen Riesen Hirsch
auseinander zu nehmen und gleichzeitig
auch noch diese ganzen Würste und so
weiterzumachen und deswegen ist die
erstmal in der Gefriertruhe gelandet und
dann verarbeiten wir das ganze Fleisch
jetzt einfach nach und nach in den
nächsten Wochen
[Musik]